quand j'étais en troisième j'ai été très
amoureux c'était une première
mon premier amour très très fort qui en
fait tu crois avant que tu as été
amoureux mais c'est en fait il ya non en
fait c'est ça c'est ça et puis on est
arrivé au lycée et donc que ça le
premier trimestre s'était plutôt pas mal
passé
et puis elle s'en est allée dans quel
maalma les parties est normal hein c'est
parce que tu grandis pas la même vitesse
je pense que c'est pour ça j'ai eu un
énorme chagrin d'amour est complètement
désemparé par refrain est alors elle a
rencontré une dame qui lui a dire il
faut qu'il faut qu'il parte tout part de
là puisque plus on était dans la même
classe ça n'arrangeait pas les choses
cache pas qu'au niveau du bulletin qui a
suivi n'a pas été mon meilleur
cette dame lui a dit j'ai entendu parler
d'une pension pour garçons en afrique du
sud ça quatre heures d'avion d'ici c'est
en anglais et puis alors il lui
apprendre ou la discipline change parce
qu'elles sont raconte exactement et je
suis arrivé donc dans cette danse est
pension en afrique du sud à quatre
heures d'avion de chez moi où je suis
resté trois ans j'ai vécu aussi
l'histoire de ce pays en même temps que
les sud-africains la vivait j'étais là
pour l'élection de nelson mandela
donc c'était en 94 voilà c'est
je m'aime à nos âges on était jeunes on
était on avait 17 ans même à nos âges
vous savez qu'on vivait un truc
qu'historique
[Musique]
la cérémonie des césar c'est arrivé
aussi aussi un petit peu comme un comme
un rêve qui se réalisait quand même
j'avais dit à mes parents
un jour peut-être que c'est moi qui
présenterait cette cérémonie les
encouragements super termine dans
l'assiette et puis ensuite c'est comme
ça c'était pas montessori quoi la maison
d'un coup arrive l'opportunité via c'est
maxime saada qui m'appellent et qui me
propose de présenter la 43e cérémonie
des césar et c'est en marchant vers
l'avant scène en avançant pour le début
de la cérémonie sur les mots de
dominique farrugia qui dit même
messieurs veuillez accueillir votre
maître de cérémonie pour cette 43e
servis que je me dis n'empêche manu que
tu as refusé de sauter à l'élastique
mme était quand même là quoi j'aimerais
bien voir les mecs qui est en train de
me charrier sur le pont d'avignon
jusqu'au bout c'est ça un des moments
qui va changer ma vie aussi
ou du moins l'embellir et plutôt que de
me donner l'expérience de devenir un
adulte me fait garder mon âme d'enfant
c'est les quatre mois que j'ai passé
avec jean pierre marielle
tous les soirs parfois certains moments
de la pièce je me disais mais mon dieu
mais si vous saviez ce que j'ai vécu
juste avant avec lui dans la loge
vous seriez dingue et sont des histoires
qu'il n'a pas retenu car moi à la fin de
la pièce quand la pièce s'est arrêté je
pense quatre mois m'a laissé un petit
mot et jean pierre avait écrit on s'est
rencontrés on s'est rencontrés on ne se
quittera plus promet le mois ouais là on
peut parler d'un moment
qu'elle change et à livrer